ces panneaux annonçant une chasse en
cours sont de retour sur les bords des
routes solognote novembre et décembre
sont les mois les plus importants pour
les chasseurs ceux où les prélèvements
sont les plus nombreux pour la
fédération de chasse du loir et cher qui
compte dix sept mille adhérents
il était inconcevable de suspendre la
chasse en cette période nous déjà nous
avons une mission d'intérêt général
donc ça c'est quand même le but qui nous
a forcé à demander cet arrêté
préfectoral déjà pour le côté dégâts de
gibier le sanglier vis-à-vis des dégâts
agricoles par rapport aux cervidés par
rapport aux dégâts des forestiers donc
des feuillus un des arbres la forêt et
puis à côté sanitaire il faut surtout
pas oublier dans le département nous
prélevons 27 milles sans quille
nous sommes un des départements voir le
premier donc en tant que prélèvements
depuis le 29 octobre la chasse de
loisirs est suspendu seuls les chasses
déclarée en préfecture pour réguler les
espèces sont autorisés et sont limités à
des groupes de six personnes maximum
réaction des écologistes vu que les
chasseurs peuvent accéder à la forêt
alors pourquoi pas tout le monde
si les chemins forestiers sont
accessibles aux promeneurs contrairement
aux premiers confinement ils doivent en
effet se trouver à moins d'un kilomètre
de chez soi nous vivons une situation
très difficile et je crois que nous
avons toutes et tous besoin d'accéder à
la nature et que c'est un droit qu'il
nous faut pouvoir exercer et
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une rupture
d'égalité
nous demandons à ce que soit supprimé la
limitation à un kilomètre et une heure
pour les sorties autorisées pendant la
période du confinement
parce qu'évidemment pour certains c'est
plus d'une heure
c'est plus d'un kilomètre pour pouvoir
accéder à la nature et nous en avons
tous vraiment vraiment besoin
europe ecologie les verts a déposé un
recours au niveau national pour rétablir
un accès pour tous à la nature quel que
soit son lieu d'habitation